- I cried so much from one to eight.
From zero to eight Gary
Vaynerchuk cried every day.
I was so emotional, my new
hypothesis is the following.
Yeah!
You got your prospective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
YouTube, what's up?
So, so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to
watch a new YouTube video
but before you do, 212-931-5731.
That is my texting community platform,
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there
and also access opportunity, first looks
in that environment,
212-931-5731, join it now
and now to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
Hey, guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
episode 331 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Actually we had a pretty
hardcore Team Gary
meeting the other day where
we're actually gonna be
rebranding this show so
a lot of changes in store
so one of the last #AskGaryVee
Shows in this format.
Are we keeping the #AskGaryVee
and it's just gonna be me asking,
I don't even remember
how we, what we ended at.
Anyway Amy, a ton of
shit is coming as always
and Amy is back in the building.
I'm gonna allow her to introduce herself
to the Vayner Nation in a minute,
talk about this lovely book.
but I think this is one of
the last things I'm doing
content wise for the year so
happy holidays, happy New Year,
healthy to everybody, the
new decade is upon us.
And it's really good to see you, Amy.
- It's great to see you,
Gary, thanks for having me.
- Why don't you tell everybody who you are
and a little bit about
what we're doing here.
- Sure, my name is Amy Landino
and I'm a Vayner Speaker,
isn't that the only thing that matters?
(laughing)
- This is true, actually,
fun fact, Amy is part,
Vayner Speakers is a agency we have
where we rep me and I think 10 maybe or so
other exclusive artists and then others
and Amy is part of the roster,
one of the first people we reached out.
- I am, so grateful for that, by the way.
- [Gary] Have you been enjoying it?
- Oh my gosh, are you kidding?
What a team!
- Let's shoot at them,
I want to shit on Zach and
Steve and those guys if we can.
- The day he's out.
- Have they been good?
- They've been fantastic.
You know, it was at the end
of the first year I was like,
so you guys are like cool
with me staying on, right?
And they were, "Oh yeah
we're just getting started."
I mean, it's only gotten
better as we've gone along,
you guys sent me to Saudi
Arabia for crying out loud.
- [Gary] I heard, I heard, that's awesome.
- But I think what most people know me for
is a YouTube channel called Amy TV.
I help women going after
the life that they want.
I also have a podcast called
Detailed Therapy so speaking,
I just wrote my second book,
Good Morning Good Life and--
- When did this come out?
- Just a couple weeks ago.
- Self-published or?
- Self-published.
- [Gary] And how's that game been?
- It's a lot of work from the outset
but it's so worth it in the end.
I mean, it's just like, I
don't have to deal with anybody
it's just my book.
- In a world where like so
many people producing content,
what you just said is like
something I think about,
like there's so much.
What do you think has helped you succeed?
- At the end of the day,
and it goes back to the conversation of,
should you publish traditionally,
should you do a lot of things?
There was so many different options
but that's the best part about it
and also the worst part
about it, it's paralyzing.
I think the thing that's made me succeed
is the ability to make a decision.
I can make a decision
and just decide to do it
and whether it's the best
thing I could have done
or I could have done
something better, it's fine,
you reflect on it, you
move on from it, you go.
If I decide to self publish and I'm like,
hmm, should have done something.
Who cares, like whatever
progress is gonna--
- You don't dwell.
- No, I don't not at all.
Because I know that I
can just do it again,
I can just try something else,
I can just go a different way.
And there's actually not a
lot of things I can think of
where I'm like, oh man,
made the wrong move.
Because I just decide and go.
- Yeah I like that, I'm a big fan of that.
We're gonna take some calls I decided
quite a bit on this episode so
please put, what are we live on Facebook?
- Facebook Live for questions.
- Okay, and LinkedIn?
All right, cool, LinkedIn, Facebook,
please put your phone
number in the comments
and we will call you as we're gonna make
the majority the show
call in 'cause I like that
and I want to do that and
we've had Amy in the past
so you can Google us we've
jammed a bunch over the years
so yeah there's plenty backstory
and things that nature.
So what's, what are you hyped about,
what are you excited
about, what's on your mind?
What are you thinking about these days?
- I don't know I actually kind of had
like a tangent thought moment this morning
just because like I don't
think I've ever like sat down
and fully like chatted with you
in sort of this kind of format
but there's such a misconception
'cause you've been really kind to me,
you've been great to my career, my family,
but a lot of people have
approached me and gone,
"How are you like best
friends with Gary Vaynerchuk?"
And I'm just like, well, you know,
good work observes good work
and it ends up being the best example ever
when I'm talking to
people about mentorship.
Because everybody has
this like, not everybody,
but a lot of people have the wrong idea
that you have to literally be
on the phone with somebody,
talk to somebody every day, every week
for X number of minutes in
order for them to mentor you.
But that's never been the
case with you being my mentor.
I read your books, I watched your videos,
I listen to podcasts, you
told me what to do all along
but it's like, how many conversations
do we need to have in between?
And that was a moment I had this morning,
I was like, I wish more people knew
that I don't have to be your best friend
to take a good example from you
and I hope that that's what is happening
with people with me.
- So that's what you mean
with that perspective
like that people think
that our relationship,
that they need to have
that same level of access
to me to get the benefit.
- They need, yeah any access
and it looks different than it actually is
and it's because of
someone's ability to execute,
not what someone's actual access is.
- I agree, I think it has a lot to do
with the first thing that you spoke about
which is your ability not
to dwell helps you so much.
Like people second-guess
themselves beforehand and after
and that's where all the energy goes,
they're beating themselves up,
it's a game of insecurity
versus self-esteem.
This is one big game of that.
No matter how many different
cartoons or platforms
or ways I package the
story it's very, very, very
important for people to understand
the way they think about themselves
is an uncomfortable variable
to what's going to happen.
- Absolutely, I've been kind
of having this conversation
with my community lately about guilt
because it comes in a
lot of different ways,
it's packaged in a lot of different ways.
You can do it to yourself but
it can also be somebody else
trying to make you feel guilty.
And you'll actually find
that that happens a lot
when you're actually doing
something to improve yourself,
like having a morning routine
or starting a business
or saving money and not going out as much.
Guilt comes externally all the time.
But what I'm realizing more and more
is I can't feel guilty about something
that I'm doing with intention,
something I chose to do.
And so if I'm not able to do this thing
because I was able to focus
on what was important to me
because there is no shame
attached to what I do
and how I spend my time every day
that guilt just doesn't
make a connection to me
and I don't know if that's like,
oh, I lack feelings in
certain areas or whatever
but I just have been able to
compartmentalize a little bit
where I can observe someone's feelings
if they think I'm not hearing them
and say, you know, okay how do
we fix the real problem here
because it's not that I'm
too invested in my career,
that's not really the problem
at the end of the day.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
about that a lot as well.
I think so much of what works for me
is having the ability to have detachment
with what you were just referring to
which is not having feelings,
like the whole business is business,
while having deep empathy.
I have enormous compassion,
it's very easy for me to understand
but I have a complete ability
to not allow somebody else
to impose their feelings
on how I should be feeling.
I just, we live in a
keyboard warrior culture.
Like, it's it's laughable to
me that somebody who doesn't,
who's never met me can
have the energy to tell me
how to live my life.
- 100%.
- Like, it doesn't make like,
even in the way I articulated that,
like it's just common
sense, it's just like,
you know, but it leads to
what is your framework.
If you were brought up by parents
that made you feel insecure
then it's likely that Johnnypants47
has a chance to make you
insecure as well in a comment.
- And not really even knowing when,
what it sounds like for
someone to blame you
and then for you to take
that same habit forward
and use a blame mentality and an approach
in making somebody feel bad.
- I just came out of a
really tough HR meeting
where somebody went to HR
that's upset with me
about a decision I made
that is 100% grounded in
their entitlement and ego.
And I want to punch something.
Like seriously, that's, it's
just really fascinating.
Especially, the reason I
have some juice on this
is because on top of which
me bending triple backwards
to make it awesome for them,
hence why the entitlement happened.
But that's the game, that's life.
- That's the balance that I've been--
- People hate accountability.
- 100%.
The balance for me learning
as my business grows
is learning how to be a
manager and I'm like, whoa!
This is a thing I did
not sign up for, right,
and so there's that and then there's like,
okay, I want them to see
it this way but like,
who am I to say the way they see things?
So who am I to say that their ego
is not a good enough argument?
- You know what's funny is that
I have so much passion to share,
I have zero expectations of
anybody consuming my content
and acting on it, zero.
Every single person that
has gotten benefit from it
and has told me has been
complete upside, added value.
Zero expectations.
Back to, who am I?
Yes, I understand the people
are reacting to my content
because I'm a good communicator
and I'd like to think
I have something of substance
to say but I don't expect it.
There's a lot of things going
on, there's plenty of things.
- And I think the good communicators
or the people that are easy
to sort of understand and grab on to,
there's a level of extreme
that has to be the case.
Like clearly you you exemplify
extremity in some way.
I have an extreme in
different things that I do.
You can't put somebody
on every single pedestal,
it's that extreme.
- But there's different
judgments for different extremes.
I might be an extreme with my extroverted,
you know, communication style
and there's judgment to that.
I get a lot of people to,
you know, as you know,
that think I'm full of
shit or a charlatan.
Whereas somebody who's an extremely good
articulator of words
writing a beautifully
extreme LinkedIn article
does not get that judgment.
Like, you know, I'm always scared
for people to try to replicate my style.
The only thing that works for me
is I'm incapable of not being myself.
- And you have the audacity
to do it on video with audio,
like I think there's a
different emotional connection
for an audience 'cause it feels like
you're talking to them on video.
If you have achieved your
goal as a video creator
it feels like you're sitting
in the room with someone
and you're saying that to their face.
- And I think what's important is,
just like leaning into you,
like let it be known as a strategist
for success I wish my chemicals
were 25% less over the top.
There are people that immediately
within the first 40
seconds of their friend
recommending them watching content
will click, play, leave, DM
their friend or text them
and be like, what the fuck
are you talking about?
I hate that dude.
If I could take 25% less juice
out of my communication style
I would have more audience,
it's not super complicated.
- [Amy] Oh, I don't know if I agree.
- Because you're gonna argue the counter
which I probably agree with as well
which is where I was about to go which is,
but then you don't have
the audience you have
from your authenticity.
- But not just that.
I mean, clearly we see
it in every capacity,
in politics and everything,
like your ability to make
people make a decision
is where you end up
getting even more traction.
- Yeah, and to your point,
if there was 25 less,
you know, if there's one less curse or,
there was a really
interesting conversation I had
with a really nice guy on my Instagram
two days ago I think or yesterday where
there's this moment where
I'm helping this kid
make a decision around doing what he loves
versus what his mom
wants and in the moment,
we're going back and forth
and he's like, "You're right."
And I'm like, "I know I'm right."
And I'm transitioning to the next thing
and he took real issue and he's like,
"I hate that about you, like you're so,
"everything's so good and when
you come across condescending
"or high on yourself."
I'm like, you've completely
missed the context.
This is a kid in this exact moment
that's trying to make a life decision
and me creating affirmation on his idea
that wait a minute, you might be right
is exactly what's needed in that moment.
I don't need to say I'm
right for my own ego,
I'm quite confident in who I am,
I don't need to tell some
random kid, I know I'm,
that's not the moment where I'm
gonna pull out the ego card.
- I think that's the segue
to, let me tell you everything
I feel like you should hear right now,
you're taking it personal
when I say those words.
- People are literal,
he's taking it literally,
I'm like, rewatch it, rewatch it.
I know I'm right is to keep
pushing him down a path
to try to help him feel empowered.
Not me trying to be braggadocios.
I can be braggadocios a
million more interesting ways.
Resy sold for hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars to Amex,
hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars.
Me and Ben Leventhal came up
with the idea over dinner,
we incubated the company at VaynerMedia,
I sat on the board, I was
an instrumental player,
I rarely mention it.
- I was wondering whatever happened to it.
- What happened to it, Amex bought it
for hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars.
I have so much more interesting shit
to be braggadocios about
than me being right
that his mom will be happy
if he lives his life his way.
People are very funny, very literal,
really willing to take
things out of context
for the narrative they want to paint.
Let's take some phone
numbers, LinkedIn, Facebook,
put up your phone numbers.
JR here's gonna do some calls,
we want to get Amy to
answer some questions.
While John is dialing,
how's the book doing?
- It's great.
- Yeah, you're sellin' some?
- Yean, we've sold a few, yeah,
we've definitely sold some books.
It's amazing 'cause it's like
I haven't had to create
any content on Instagram,
like everybody's just posting.
- Doin' it for you.
- Hello, this is Ethan.
- Ethan its Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on the
#AskGaryVee Show with Amy.
- [Ethan] Oh my god, Gary, dude, (laughs)
I've followed you my whole
life, dude, this is insane.
- How old are you?
- For real
- 22, bro.
- 22 I've been--
- [Ethan] Dude, I'm so, I'm so fucking,
I've been an entrepreneur
my whole life, dude,
yeah when I was in high school--
- Hold on, hold on, Ethan,
real quick, say hello to Amy.
- It's fine, Ethan.
- [Ethan] How are you?
- I'm doing great, please
proceed with your story.
- [Ethan] Okay, this is awesome, anyways
I am a total entrepreneurial kid, dude,
been started a lawn mowing
business when I was little,
I started a snow cone
shock in high school,
I came to college, I started
at drinks and treats business
in Salt Lake City and I've, all
I do is work, dude, and I'm,
I've just been an
entrepreneur my whole life
and you're just my hero, Gary,
thank you so much for everything, bro,
thank you so, so much, man.
- You're welcome, Ethan.
Do you have a question,
is there something Amy and I can answer?
- [Ethan] Yeah, I do have
a question, so I'm 22,
I'm a bit younger but I
built a pretty big business
here in Salt Lake, like I was saying,
it's a drinking treat shop, right.
So what we sell is like
soda and treats, cookies,
cinnamon rolls, pretzels,
things to go with it, right.
And we do most of our business
through the drive-through.
And we have few location,
we have a few locations
we do catering, and it's grown pretty,
I've owned the business, I
started it four years ago.
I've owned the business
for about four years,
I've kind of built my personal brand
on the back of my business's content.
So we have a really popular Instagram page
here in Salt Lake.
- What's it called?
- It's @ThirstDrinks.
T-H-I-R-S-T D-R-I-N-K-S, Thirst Drinks,
the business is called Thirst.
Anyways, I'm always on
there, hey, what up,
I call my audience, honestly,
dude, I ripped this from you,
I started following you so long ago,
I listen your content so much
I started calling my
audience the Thirsty Nation.
So I'm always on the
stories everyday like,
Thirsty Nation, what
up, we got this product.
Anyways, people, and I'm
always at the shop working 24/7
so I've kind of built a personal brand
like indirectly from my business.
And but I mean, I'm 22,
I'm wondering how I can build
a personal brand because
to kind of you know leverage this
into the next thing that I do?
You know, I've built my personal brand
off of the back of my business's brand
but the problem is I
struggle to put my finger on
where I have to put my personal content
because I know, I feel
like I know a lot of shit,
like I've been working a long time--
- Yeah, you're intuitive,
you're intuitive,
you're no different than I was at that,
like so much of the reason
that I've innovated and been
unique is I didn't learn it,
it was intuitive, I did it,
I saw that it worked, I talked about it.
The answer to your question's very simple,
there's a VaynerMedia Instagram page,
there's a Wine Library Instagram page,
there's an Empathy Wines Instagram page,
there's also a GaryVee Instagram page.
You should put your personal
content on your personal page.
What you need to get--
- But your opinion though,
I know you're against like,
dude and I fucking hate,
I'm like a brick-and-mortar
retail business entrepreneur,
a young one real as I can get,
but I know I'm not I'm not
building a social media agency,
you know, like I'm not
a bullshitter, like,
you know how many fake entrepreneurs
are putting out content
about how, you know?
- But what's that got to do with you?
Like, why don't you have an Instagram page
that you're putting out
content on your page?
- [Ethan] I do but I struggle
to put my finger on where--
- No, no, no, let's, where
what, where to put the content?
- [Ethan] No, no, what
kind of content because--
- Why don't you, no you
don't, no you don't.
- [Ethan] I'm documenting my journey.
- No you don't, you really don't have,
like I can tell it in these
3 minutes and 41 seconds
that you do not have a problem
figuring out what to post on it,
you just have too much to say.
- [Ethan] I don't want to
be a bullshitter, dude.
- So don't bullshit.
Hold on, hold on, what,
you think that people,
have you been affected by me saying that
don't be a 22 year old life
coach, are you, like let me--
- [Ethan] 100%, yeah, yeah, but I see 'em.
- Good, so let's chip at it.
People think that I'm
a motivational speaker,
I don't want to be, what's
one of the ways to do that?
By building an actual $200 million agency
with a thousand employees globally
to starting a speaking
bureau that is actually good
and Amy still likes us because
we send her to Saudi Arabia.
Like, don't put out
anything that isn't true.
- [Ethan] Right, and I feel like,
how do I be grounded to that
because I haven't built anything like you
but like that's a million
dollar business, you know,
just a local retail business.
- Talk about what happened today
when the manager called out
sick and you had to go there.
I wish I made content when
I was building Wine Library,
there was real ass shit there.
I would argue that my running
hypothesis is your problem is
that your account doesn't
have any followers yet
and the humility needed
after you've built up the
business's following count
to start yours now with
no followers is a bridge
that's a little bit
difficult to cross right now.
- [Ethan] I don't think so
but I also on that point,
I have a tactic that I, kind
of stems from your content
that I think everyone's gonna really like.
I created an account
called Ethan from Thirst,
that's literally my username.
- I see it.
- [Ethan] and I go in and I
engage with the community,
my Thirst Drinks community.
So when I post something in the comments
I instead of commenting
back from Thirst's account
I'll go in from Ethan from Thirst
just from that little personal touch,
just that extra authenticity
just so they know that
the owner is caring.
- I love that.
- I'm really doing that.
- I believe it, I see it,
Amy, did you have some
and while I'm looking?
- I mean, like my question is like,
we all know that documenting,
creating content is a great idea
but at the same time like,
why do you want to build
the personal brand?
Like you directly connected
it to why Gary is doing it,
he has an agency all of
these assets help him
but at the same time, I get it
if the personal brand's
gonna help you in some way
you can't even fathom yet
down the road, that's great,
but if you know why you're
going to talk to an audience
on a different site, on
a different platform,
on a different account,
you'll know who you're
talking to a little bit better
because it it doesn't sound to me
like you're talking to
the Thirst audience,
'cause that's why you would
post on the Thirst account.
Why are you posting on Ethan's account,
who are you talking to?
Because the more you look at
the camera like it's a person
the more it's gonna feel like
you're connecting with them
and you have to know who
that person is really well
in order to do that.
- [Ethan] Right, I wanna build up my brand
'cause I guess I want the
leverage for the next thing.
- That's right, that's exactly right.
- [Ethan] I feel like
I've built a huge business
as a pretty young kid and
I'm like, hey, this is cool,
I want people to know about it
so that I can go to the next
thing and they'll follow me.
- By the way, I think that's right
and looking at your
account my question is,
what's the problem?
- [Ethan] Just putting my content,
like should I share my tips and tricks,
should I only be documenting, you know?
- Ah, let's see let's
go back to that point,
thank you for that.
Let's really--
- [Ethan] I'm wondering
do I share my knowledge
that I feel like I have--
- Why wouldn't you?
- [Ethan] Because of the
bullshitters out there, you know.
- No, no, no, no, that
makes no sense to me,
let's stay on this, Ethan.
You wouldn't share
tactics that you've used
to build up your business
because you're worried that
somebody who's full of shit
and makes pretender
entrepreneur will do what?
Play with me here.
- No, I don't care about
them, I'm more worried about,
I don't wanna be perceived as one of those
just like you're talking
about all these bullshitters--
- But you're putting out content now.
Like, I'm looking at your content,
you you have a post on your
account of a screenshot
where you text somebody about, you know,
an increase of 50% in sales.
I don't think you're worried
about the bullshit part,
I think you just might
not actually want to share
the information because you might think
it's a competitive advantage.
- [Ethan] No, no.
- Okay, so then why wouldn't you share it?
- [Ethan] I guess just because,
dude, I'm in the mix of it.
I go to the University Utah,
I see these guys like just
bullshitting, you know,
like starting social
media marketing companies.
- I'm wildly confused why you
think that matters to you.
I see them too, they
all copy me every day.
I think about them zero, why
are you thinking about them?
- If it's a perception issue
is it because you only feel
like you can post something
when you have a hard metric to offer
that can prove that you
know what you're doing
and you don't feel like talking
in hyperbole other times
'cause it's like it could
be perceived any which way?
- [Ethan] Maybe.
- But he's doing it.
But you're doing it, like, but you post
a three-minute nine video titled,
it's not about the likes
comments or followers
and then there's gonna be three minutes
of you here talking into the mic.
You're doing all the behaviors,
like you look like a huckster to me.
The only thing that keeps you from not,
I look like a huckster to people too, bro.
The only thing that keeps one
away from not being a huckster
is not being a huckster.
- Right.
- It's permission.
- [Ethan] That's maybe why
I'm so defensive about it
'cause I'm like, dude,
I built a real business
and I want to be like,
I don't wanna fucking be
associated with those people,
I'm like, I'm the real, like you know.
- You won't be associated with
them, you built a business,
You're not associated with them.
Bro, everybody thinks I'm
exactly like some of the people
that are the worst hucksters of them all.
There's nothing I can do
about that, that's on them.
You're just worried about
other people's opinions
way too much.
- Which is really funny
to me because if the why
is that you want to
leverage this in the future
that's based on other people's opinions.
So I feel like you need
to kind of draw the line,
I think we talked about it a
little bit before the call,
if you're making this decision,
if you don't have any
shame in what you're doing,
if you're a success at it
and you want to show it to the world
it's very easy to let
everyone's now opinions
keep you from doing
something but the bandwagon,
once it gets going
people will jump on board
but you gotta keep it up.
- And Ethan, I have a news report for you.
If you don't make content
the hucksters are gonna
keep making content.
So what are we doing here, the
fuck are you accomplishing?
- [Ethan] We're building real
businesses out here, man.
- So build it, so let's go
back to why you're asking,
Amy, go ahead, I saw you
want to say something.
- Well, so now it's like,
you don't want to look like everybody else
that's a huckster and there ego
but you're using your ego as an excuse
as to why you're not going to share it
because you're like, oh, I'm
doing real business over here,
I can't possibly make the
time to talk about it.
But you can because you know it's valuable
because you're smarter than that.
- [Ethan] I don't feel like I'm insecure,
I mean, I've branded myself
as this little soda shop boy
that sells to moms coming
to the drive through,
I'm not worried about it that way.
I guess, in parallel I'm asking like,
how do I do this too because
I'm running a small business,
I can't hire a DRock, you
know, we all start small--
- No no, but bro, let's
just take a step back,
like, this is real life now.
Like, when I started doing Twitter in 2007
Wine Library was doing $50
plus million in business,
I was super busy, had 100 employees
and I did all my own
social media, made content,
and engaged with community,
I just went to sleep at
three o'clock in the morning
'cause I was trying to win
the whole fucking thing.
Now I don't recommend that for everybody,
like not everybody wants
that, not everybody does that.
But it's doable, I don't know
what you're talking about,
there's people running way
bigger businesses than you
at the same age who are making
content, like it's not super.
The question becomes, I
think that there's some stuff
that you have to get real
with yourself on about it.
A, you know, the truth is undefeated.
So regardless of what I
say or you say or we say
or Amy says or they say in the comments,
if you're a real entrepreneur
and you build a real business
that's how it's gonna play out, right.
B, I think you're, especially
if you're following
your whole life, for years,
you know how valuable personal
brand can be for leverage,
I think you're on the right track.
I think that you might be
better at being an entrepreneur
than you are at being a content
creator and communicator
or you're lacking patience
or you do over value judgment
or you'd like to see more traction
and it's causing friction,
all these things are real
conversations which are all fine.
Listening to this and when you
watch these 13 minutes back
the complete unlock because we
asked all the right questions
is gonna be where do you need
to get real with yourself
that you didn't get in this call?
I promise you, Ethan, that is the answer.
- [Ethan] Mm-hmm, thank you so much, Gary.
- Ethan, one thing that might help you is
go back and watch, go back and look
at all my Tweets from 2007,
it'll take you 15 minutes
but go back and find them.
The team did this recently,
I think one of them,
the Tweet they used in the
content I got two likes.
No retweets, no comments, two likes.
- [Dustin] Some were none.
- You know, some were
none, thank you, Dustin.
- [Ethan] Gary, you know
what everyone asks me
'cause I'm yelling about text
because it's just blowing
up my business right now,
text marketing is.
Do you know how it fits
into a small business
because it's kind of expensive
for a small business?
Like it costs me five cents
of text to send these out
and I know you're yelling
about it, do you know anything,
does your team know anything
about how this can work
for small businesses?
I mean, if have a 10,000 person
text list that's 500 bucks.
- Yeah, but you haven't
amortized out the value in return yet.
- [Ethan] No, I see it,
but I'm just wondering--
- Well, real quick,
real quick, you see it,
how many, ready, let's be real,
I think you're gonna like this,
how many people are on
text platform right now?
- [Ethan] I have about
almost 11,000 texts.
- Is it worth $500 a text for you?
- [Ethan] A couple times a month.
But it works so good, my
customers love it so much,
I'm trying to figure out--
- Are you selling on it
or is it you're using it
as a service to them?
- [Ethan] I'll use it
as a, hey, this weekend
we're gonna be baking fresh soft pretzels,
we'd love to see, you
have a great weekend.
And picture of the pretzels
or something like that.
- Yeah, so I think, A, I
think five cents a text
is too expensive from what
I can recall in my head.
Like, for example, actually,
actually, you're gonna love me right now,
I'm literally gonna give
you a real piece of data.
There was a text we sent
out, let's see here,
just want to make sure I get
this, give me 40 seconds.
Actually will it be here?
No, give me 40 seconds
Amy, keep him occupied.
(laughs)
- I mean, like to me it
sounds like it's working great
and I'm curious to hear
like what the issue is,
it's expensive absolutely
but if it's bringing you business,
if you've seen a movable difference,
are you seeing more than a
$500 difference that weekend?
- [Ethan] Oh, you would think
I was handing out free money
when I send out these texts.
- Ethan, send me an email,
send me an email to Gary@Vaynermedia,
we sent out 9,191, 9,191 texts
today, it cost us 248.72.
So you might just be going
with a service provider
that's got a premium so right there
we've saved you two
hundred fifty bucks a text.
- [Amy] It sounds like it's worth it.
- [Ethan] This is, for
your following too, Gary,
'cause I know a lot of
them are small businesses,
if you export that your POS data
90% percent of the time that
has phone numbers in it.
And if you text those customers
they will come running back,
I got that from you, I did it.
- You better make sure that
your compliance though,
like you don't extract
the numbers and text cold
'cause there's a lot of
compliance issues with texting
for everybody who's listening so I think--
- [Amy] And we do not wanna
kill this industry already.
- I think what you want to do there--
- [Ethan] Well what we
do is a loyalty system
so if you want points
back to get a free drink.
- Yeah, if you make a promise up front
that you're gonna text people are open
to letting their text open.
Ethan, rewatch this and
deploy some true answers
to yourself about it and go execute.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- All right, bye bye.
Let's get another call in, that was fun.
It's really interesting,
I mean, I think, you know,
what's fun about that call is
there's a lot of good ingredients there.
- 100%, and he's 22.
- It's amazing.
And he's got it.
Like, he built a fucking
business already, a real one,
like a real one.
- He's hitting the ground running
and it's so easy to get
tripped up by opinions,
especially this young in life
but in general he's probably--
- I just think he wants to build up
a much bigger social media platform
but he doesn't want to be a douche bag.
Hello?
- This is Calvin.
- Calvin, this is Gary--
- [Calvin] What's up Amy, what's up, Gary?
- How are you, Calvin?
- Hello!
- [Calvin] Doing well, good
to be back on the show.
- Thanks, Calvin.
- So, Gary, I asked you on
episode 202 two about celebrating
and I think Amy asked you
something around it once too
about like how do you get the energy back
after doing something big,
both of you guys are up
to really big things.
- Calvin is on his shit.
- And around this time of year
we have so many people about
set New Year's resolutions
and aiming bigger and I'm
just curious for both of you,
Amy and Gary, like first of all,
what are you celebrating
right now to end 2019
and more importantly how are
your sights now set on 2020?
Like how do you goal set,
how do you vision set,
like what's going on?
- You first, Amy.
- I mean, I'm excited about my new book.
That's pretty much my 2019.
I mean, like the end of a decade,
this is our heyday at
Amy TV, like January,
new year new me, it's a new decade,
like we're just gonna have
so much fun with that.
But you also can't get
so engrossed in that.
It's very easy to have
New Year's resolutions,
it's totally different thing to execute
and to actually stick with something.
A habit isn't a habit 'cause
you called it a habit,
it's a habit because
it becomes a habitual.
So I think that's a lot
of what's in front of me.
I mean, like is helping people understand
that they actually have the time
to do the things that they want to do
if they care about it that much
and, Gary, you've talked
about this ad nauseam,
how late are you watching
Netflix at night,
what could you be doing?
By the way, it's very easy
to get seven hours of sleep
if, you know, you wanna wake up early
and do the thing that you want to do.
And I have such a totally
different perspective,
I think about where I was 10 years ago,
it's probably when I discovered
Gary, read Crush It in 2009,
totally different place in my life.
I've had tragedy happen, I've
had beautiful things happen,
I've had high of highs happen,
I just wrote my second book
which is really weird.
I'm very excited to be able
to take what I've learned,
especially in the last couple of years
into the next stage in my life
because I think it's the best place
that my headspace could be right now.
To be realistic about the fact
that we're so lucky to breathe every day.
- Yeah, there is no
micro event, Resy selling
or Vayner being positioned for a big year
or a sneaker deal, a car
deal, a wine company,
like there's no micro
event, even family stuff,
kids getting older, you know, family time,
even that I call a micro event.
I don't celebrate because
I'm always celebrating.
I don't celebrate micro,
I truly celebrate macro.
I'm literally one of these people,
you know, it's funny, I'm not religious
but I'm definitely spiritual.
Like I literally wake up and I'm like--
- [Calvin] You have not talked
about this enough, Gary,
I just have to say.
- Yeah, I agree with you.
- [Calvin] The spiritual
side and things like that.
- Because you know what's funny,
because you know what's funny?
I'm trying to find different
angles to say the same thing
'cause I want, I'm
hoping to use something,
even the way you're reacting, and Calvin,
you're on your shit if you knew 202
and you knew Amy asked me that question
so you're consuming and you
have context and you're right,
I don't know if I've
ever even used spiritual,
I think maybe one other time
if I'm like kind of feeling it.
The reason I'm saying that is
I don't think people hear me.
I really mean it when I say
that I woke up this morning
and I was like you, phew,
no phone call in the middle of the night
that I have to run to the hospital.
Phew, super pumped I'm
not in heaven right now
'cause that, you know
that, brain hemorrhage--
- Sounds like a great place, yeah.
- Like, you know, like I don't celebrate
because I'm actually celebrating
and it's kind of how I
think about meditating
and it's how I kind of
think about balance.
Like, I've got some gear inside of me
that has a deep perspective
that puts me in such a good place
that I'm celebrating everything
and nothing, you know,
and that's that, like I don't
know, like everything's--
- [Calvin] But the thing is with you
that's so interesting is,
what's so interesting about you though
is a lot of people get that
from something, usually,
they usually get that from their religion,
maybe they found some other
guru or they read something,
you haven't done any of that shit.
- I found it within myself.
You know what's funny?
I've been thinking about
lately this thought.
Was I so, I cried so
much from one to eight,
from zero to eight Gary
Vaynerchuk cried every day.
I was so emotional, my new
hypothesis is the following.
Huh, I am so empathetic,
and when I say crying,
when I was sad, when my mom was sad,
when I saw somebody else was sad,
like watching a movie,
TV, I didn't like the way
that person got picked on
in first grade, I cried.
Like literally this is
scene in my head right now,
somebody get, I know what it is,
a kid got picked on in class,
I see it, I just start crying.
My belief is that I
might be so empathetic.
- [Amy] You like people a lot.
- That I think I started
building a reverse behavior
of detachment to even get
through by being so empathetic
that I created some sort
of thing within myself
that made me go the complete
other way to make life palpable
and I practiced it so hard
and that I probably was
naturally born so empathetic
and that my counter-reaction was to
detach myself from those feelings
that I'm now playing at such a bridge of,
I don't give a fuck, I
care about everybody.
- This is what I've always
been confused about with you
'cause I feel like, I operate
at very similar levels
than you all the time but
I am 100% introverted.
I know how to be on when I need to be on,
I love connecting with
people in a conversation,
I don't need to look at my phone--
- I would I would argue I have
introverted characteristics,
I'm wildly good at being by myself.
- [Amy] You're both,
you're 100% percent both.
- And I'm real extreme on both too.
Like I think I recognize
that in you too and like my,
and it's not better or worse,
I think you might be
here and I might be here
and in that is even something
'cause I definitely know what happens
in between this and this,
that's my that's my theory right now.
I think I got it from within myself
out of a correction of maybe being
too feelings oriented early on
and then I think it became patterns
and building and building and building.
I'm telling you, I couldn't
explain to everybody here
enough of how much crying I did
in the first five to
eight years of my life,
I was constantly crying.
I cried every time I lost in
anything until I was like 15.
It's weird when you're
13 with your buddies,
you lose in like, you know,
like in like Nintendo football
and you're like crying
and like punching walls,
I'm hyper on emotionally
and I think to get through I created--
- Well, you learned that
it didn't do anything
it sounds like.
- [Gary] Yeah, or like it was exhausting.
- Yeah, it's like okay,
so, we're still doing that
and it's not doing anything.
- It's funny that when you just said that
like I went into a place of like, no,
I think it was exhausting.
And I think that's why I am I am.
- [Calvin] So to tie that to
goal setting, you mentioned--
- I want to be the number
one person on Earth,
I don't give a fuck if
nothing happens, that's it.
- [Calvin] So you're in that good balance.
So when you have a new year,
so you have this big macro thing
of some day buying the New
York Jets and there's that
and then you're in the
trenches every day--
- But that's a front for me
just to keep playing forever.
- It's so easy to latch on to.
It's not the thing.
- It's like a least thing,
the thing is the process
of trying and then--
- It's like, here's why
I'm still going, guys,
still don't own the Jets.
- [Calvin] So here's my
question, my question is,
with a new year coming up,
I know you usually take time
off at the end of the year,
are you actually planning
and making up goals for 2020
or are you just like, what's
fuckin' comin' on Monday?
- No, that's right.
But I'm a plan the next
15 years on an insight
that I pick up on March
16th walking down to my car
at 6:03 p.m. during a rainstorm
and might say, wait a minute.
I'm in complete and utter
motion at all times.
I'm in strategy all the time,
I don't sit down and write
out it on paper and say,
oh these last three years, and by the way,
that's my strength and my weakness.
I just still think I'm
early, I eat my own advice.
I believe at 44 years old
that I'm not in panic mode
on my great ambitions.
- [Calvin] Love it, how about you, Amy?
- I mean, like I look at
my goals every single day
and they mattered they matter to me,
I'm rewriting them every day
but at the same time I feel like
they're my version of the Jets.
Like I enjoy everything
I'm doing on a daily basis,
if my goals change in a couple of days
or a couple weeks, a couple months
it doesn't completely rock my world
because I know I'm
constantly moving forward.
I think the problem becomes
if you become so much of a goal
person or resolutions person
but you're never actually
hitting any marks,
that can be troubling,
that can be difficult.
But I feel very much on
the same page as Gary
that it's like, these are
helping me to make sure
I stay on point with my why,
they're helping me to not get distracted
by whatever I saw on
Instagram that looks cool.
Like, okay cool, that's my new goal.
No, it's not, it's somebody else's
and it's okay to be happy for them.
But having something that I
know drives me to focus on
keeps me focused every day
so I'm not getting into the nitty-gritty
and all the drama's of the day.
But then really I'm happy
to take everything in stride
the way that it goes.
- [Gary] 'Cause that's fucking life.
- It is, like you can't change that.
- Crying about the fact that
you took on college debt
because now you listen to me
you're like, fuck, he's right.
Like--
- So now what?
- There's no fucking time machine.
Like can we just fucking
go there once and for all,
there is no time machine,
you're not going into a time machine
and every second you dwell about something
that has already happened or
completely out of your control
is a second you're not
using on the solution.
- And also the news is just like loving
that you're sitting on
this because they're like,
hey, hey, we might
forgive all student debt,
we might and you could qualify.
I'm not sitting here waiting
to see how that works out for somebody.
It's like, you've got to
make that change on your own
and maybe if something
good happens along the way
it's 'cause you were working so hard at it
on the day to day.
- Wiping out somebody's mistake
is the quickest way to make
sure they make it again.
- [Calvin] Last question,
to Amy, if I can.
- Please.
- Sure.
- [Calvin] Okay, so Amy, first of all,
congratulations for being
a part of Vayner Speakers,
that's freakin' rad.
- Thank you.
- [Calvin] My question is
for some of us new guys
that are just up and comers
what advice would you give
or how to get signed with
something like Vayner Speakers
to turn up, I mean, I've been doing
a little bit of public speaking
for last couple of years
but I want to turn it up like a lot
and so I'm just curious
what advice you'd have
to either be signed with an
agency like Vayner Speakers
or yeah, just what would
you do to do more speaking?
- Getting signed with an agency
was never really on my radar,
I think I knew that there was something
like that would be advantageous to that
but never in my wildest
dreams did I think,
oh, it's gonna be my buddy
Gary that starts an agency
and then, so I have two answers.
A, get a significant other that
will Tweet Gary and be like,
why isn't Amy on your speaking roster
'cause shout-out to Vinny,
he's my number one sales guy.
- Honestly, I'm gonna
give a counter to that.
Vinny's probably the biggest reason
Amy doesn't have more
opportunities with me
because he's bugging the shit out of me
and every time he leaves me alone
I actually give Amy more ops.
I'm joking, that was
just to get Vinny goin'.
Keep goin'.
- [Calvin] So the first rule
is to not annoy Gary, okay.
- I'm sorry to interrupt,
'cause I actually
like the way you communicate
so I actually think
you've got a shot here,
whatever great advice Amy's about to give
I just really want you to
know the answer is content.
- Calvin, when I wanted to
take speaking seriously I did.
In 2015 I was like if
anyone allows me to speak
from an application or asked me to speak
I'm gonna pay whatever
it takes to get there.
I went to the Philippines,
I went to Manchester, UK,
I went everywhere and I spoke
on 15 16, 17 stages that year.
I spent a lot of money and
travel but I got experience.
And then what happens,
people watch you on YouTube
for whatever reason they
think you can talk to
1,000 people in an audience
when you're sitting alone in
a bedroom talking to a camera
but it still worked out,
content in that capacity
plus actually getting out
and getting experience.
And then everybody was
like, you gotta write a book
so that helped.
- [Calvin] So, I have that piece down
where I have experience, I've
got to be on some fun stages.
Spoke in Salt Lake City last year
with Mel Robbins, Tom Bilyeu,
Jay Shetty and a few others
but it's just not that much.
- Do you email every, I emailed
every single tech conference
when I was doing Wine Library TV
I emailed every single tech conference
that I could get on a Google
Alert and emailed them
and ask them if they
would have me to speak.
- Okay, so don't annoy you but go ahead
and just reach out to everybody else
and that's the way to get in.
- Or annoy me.
The game is about asking
- And at the end of the day like
there's not gonna be one clear-cut way.
The loudest person still
wins a lot of the time.
Like, if they are consistent,
if they're persistent,
and the one thing that I've always had is
I've had staying power.
Like for me if I'm just
talking about me at this point
I have been producing
content for 10 years.
I have stuck around, it's not been,
when are you gonna give up on YouTube?
I'm not giving up on YouTube
until they give up on the world
like I'm just gonna keep
doing what I know how to do
in the best capacity that I know how.
I promise you, especially now
where everybody's talking about
how, what's the word, not,
super busy, super crazy,
the amount of content
that's out there is just,
it's a lot, it's saturated
and that's a great excuse
but it's also kind of true.
But if you hang tight
on what your thing is
and you're the best at it and
you just keep staying there
and you're the last guy
standing at the end of the day
like someone's gonna discover you.
If nothing else the persistence--
- Or you might suck at it,
I could paint every day,
I don't know, my intuition
is like, I'll be decent.
Like, you know, I ended up
being great at speaking.
But Calvin, I think you
need to put more reps in.
Bothering an agent,
like here's where
everybody makes a mistake.
Vayner Speakers, CAA, William Morris,
please sign me so you do the
work for me and it's easy.
What you need to do--
- [Calvin] Well, I think what I, go ahead.
- What you need to do is you need to email
every single conference, all of them.
Do you need another speaker?
Do you need another speaker,
do you need another speaker?
Everybody wants--
- [Amy] Do you need somebody
to introduce your speakers?
- Yeah, like just, it's work.
- Do anything.
- It takes years and years and years.
Like, it's just so funny with like
obviously both of you know this
and now I'm looking at your photo
so I know exactly who we're talking to,
like, Calvin, you know
this, Amy knows this,
I've been doing this for a
long, long, long, long time.
Like now it seems like all your friends,
like now people really do know me.
Like I've definitely taken that next step
in the last 24 to 36 months
but both of you knew I was a little,
I was a big deal in our
little circle, right?
But you know, like they're
all different steps
and before that I wasn't a
big deal in that little circle
and I was a wine retailer.
- Watching you go on the on The
Tonight Show and and do wine
feels like a nostalgic moment
we're all reflecting on
from a former life, it's
not like oh, he's on Fallon,
it's like, oh, he's doing this again.
- [Calvin] Everybody kept
wondering, who's hosting this?
Is this Jimmy Fallon's
show or Gary's show?
- Calvin, you wanna hear
something really, really funny?
They cut it out but we're doing the skit.
- [Calvin] Oh no.
- Yeah, it was really funny to that point.
We're doing the skit and
I see the producers say,
one more minute and I go and
Jimmy's like doing something,
I'm like Jimmy, like let's hurry up here,
we got about 30 seconds.
And he just like turns to me and goes,
the hell, this is my show!
They took it out, I thought
they're gonna keep it.
It was even worse than you think,
they edited it to the
best of their abilities.
I mean, look, when I see
the producers I just know.
Speaking of which, we gotta
get the fuck out of here.
Calvin, love you, see you, bye.
Amy, thank you so much.
Everybody who's watching,
please support wonderful woman
who I think has a lot of perspectives
that I obviously resonate
with and more importantly
just like there was a
single piece of content
that was the 87th time you heard me say it
but in that way it broke through,
my intuition is for a far majority of you
that I've not been able to break through
or paint the picture, maybe
this book does and so,
I assume it's super, I'm sure
it's under 20 bucks though,
how much is this thing?
- It's under, it's 19.99.
(laughing)
- That was so fun.
Support Amy's book, it
would mean a lot to me,
that would be your
Christmas present to me.
So, see ya, thank you.
(upbeat music)